du vergisst dir was du bist gut parierte
bisschen pole pistole und kohle gehört
nach fort und weise wie schabowski in
polen zeigt ihr lang zeigt ihre
landsleute zeigt manchmal an den rand
des denunzierenden könnte man fast sagen
gerät zweifellos gibt es alle tdi von
denen sie erzählt in polen tatsächlich
im politischen alltag
es gibt vorurteile es gibt eine starke
dominanz der katholischen kirche aber
die art und weise wie schon noch sky in
die maske das zeug hat eine leichte
erholung die polnische regisseurin im
allgäu vater schon oscar erzählt in
ihrem film die maske vom leben in polen
in der provinz
es geht überhaupt nichts sagen es gibt
überhaupt nichts ankommt so dass auch
englisch sagen hat looser und was zum
teufel willst du da die lassen uns nicht
mehr rein die wollen keine schlacken
also du vergisst dir was du bist pole
bis zum rhein du bist ein pole und ein
pole wird nach polen
bis zur pause stand a10 ist mit seinen
plänen nicht allein ihr liebster mal
eine frau aus dem dorf auch sie möchte
weg auch sie hat schon ganz konkrete
pläne
und so erzählt die erste halbe stunde
des films die maske zuerst einmal davon
wie jacek und maler sichere zukunft
vorstellen und wie ich in die zukunft
planen
die musst du hierbleiben der grund ist
eben jene statue denn er arbeitet auf
der baustelle als einer der bauarbeiter
die dieses ungetüm aus beton errichten
auf dieser baustelle eigentlich eignet
sich dann jeder unfall der dem ganzen
film die maske die entscheidende wende
gibt
ihr ziel ist das opfer dieses unfalls er
überlegt also wenn es um einen sehr
hohen preis er bekommt ein neues gesicht
aus medizinischer sicht ist das eine
ausgesprochene meisterleistung aus
seiner persönlichen sicht ist es
allerdings ein zwiespältiger segen denn
er hat zwar überlebt aber er ist im
grunde nicht mehr dasselbe
das alles das film der kameramann des
films michael glatt der auch mit mal
geschah schon oscar gemeinsam das
drehbuch geschrieben hat
auf eine ganz eigentümliche weise und
spricht von einem tilt shift verfahren
das sorgt dafür sind den bildern immer
nur ein teil scharf gestellt ist und
rundherum verschwimmt alles das ist ein
ästhetischer effekt der dem film eine
ganz eigene anmutung gibt und man kann
auch ein bisschen darüber nachdenken was
die regisseurin sich dabei wohl gedacht
hat für mich ist das auch ein bisschen
eine effekte eine bilder zum teil
grotesk wirken lässt und es hat auch
etwas von groteske was marco sadowski in
die maske von der polnischen
gesellschaft uns zeit
[Musik]